for me as a as a writer across all kinds
of genres and disciplines whether it's
screenwriting or literary fiction or
obscene fake children's books humor is
always one of the most important tools
in my palette there are things that you
can get people to come to the table on
if you make them laugh that they'll
never sign on for if you don't it's
always you know a problem to be too
pedantic to hit people over the head so
you know things like satire and
absurdity are both important ways to
engage and start a conversation and also
fundamentally at this point critical
ways to look at the world you know and I
think all of those things are heightened
when you're dealing with faith because
it's so divisive it's so important to
people and at the same time feelings
intentions around it also run incredibly
high so for me you know with this
Haggadah in particular and some of the
other work I've done in the past around
faith around Judaism around religion as
an identity and something that gets
weaponized and something that people
pick up and put down as they see fit and
as they need to the Jewish community
that Jewish faith is an interesting one
because you can be Jewish without being
religious you can be Jewish without
believing in anything you know you find
Jews who say like I'm Jewish but
I'm Buddhist you know you don't like
Episcopalians don't say like that
you know what I mean for me as somebody
who grew up culturally Jewish but in a
very secular family and household and
community Judaism in particular has
margins that are wide and very well
populated in the sense that there are
many ways to be like alienated from the
faith and yet not want to separate
yourself entirely and in my mind that's
really where all the good art comes from
is the margins of any community the
people who feel like they have one foot
in and one foot out the people who feel
invested yet not entirely accepted etc
when I look at the the Jewish artists in
particular
that I connect with who resonate with me
you know I find folks like Lenny Bruce
Woody Allen Philip Roth Bernard Malamud
Norman Mailer none of these people were
like hardcore in the bosom of Judaism
they all felt that sense of marginality
of alienation and that's where the pain
and the see art come from so I think you
know humor plays directly into that you
have to have a sense of humor about it
you have to explore the fissures and the
ways in which space is absurd the ways
in which are constructing any community
on this arbitrary set of ancient
principles that folks may or may not
even invest in in the current day and
age there's something hilarious about
that arm and the part of a Jewish
tradition in particular that I connect
with is the idea of arguing about
everything incessantly forever and the
sensibility and the humor that have
allowed folks to persevere through a lot
of horrible throughout the
centuries and maintain some some grace
in the face of all that so for me
ultimately Judaism comes down to the
jokes
[Music]